we're a hundred days out from the start
of the Summer Olympics and that means
Bob Costas mr. Olympics joining us live
from Rio how popular are you in Rio Bob
well first of all hola dan and down by
by my unofficial calculations i would
say that one in every six to seven
million brazilians knows me by name I'm
awfully proud of that so you sound
fluent in uh in Spanish right now so
that actually they speak Portuguese yeah
in in brazil butt hola apparently works
across both lines oh good good yeah
that's so you're fluent in both
languages is what you're saying
full-blown enough to greet somebody
after that I'm kind of on my own
floundering around as usual all right um
when you get first get there like do you
know the Olympics are going to be there
a hundred days out it's it they mean
what do we see when we when we land in
Rio it isn't something that's everywhere
you look at this point but right now
speaking to you from Copacabana beach
which is not only one of the most
visually arresting settings you could
ever imagine but it's the site of the
beach volleyball where Kerri Walsh
Jennings and others will go out it and
where maybe the party atmosphere that
they hope will prevail and and be the
lasting impression rather than the
various issues that they face leading up
to the games the party atmosphere should
be at its peak night and day here on
Copacabana beach so you do get some of
that feeling but I think it will be
maybe a month or so from now before the
whole city begins to feel like an
Olympic city biggest story going in
right now and granted you know we're
three months out but Michael Phelps
Usain Bolt's or is there other if you
were going to check the box of biggest
story
well in terms of competition if you look
at it not from an American viewpoint I
think what you saying both has a chance
to do might be greater this time around
then what Michael Phelps has a chance to
do in Fell's his crowning achievement
was Beijing in 2008 that's one bolt said
his world record and stunned the entire
planet are not just by beating everybody
but leaving them in his in his dust but
now he's trying to win the hundred and
the two hundred and anchor before by 100
sweet those three gold medals for third
consecutive Olympics so in terms of a
signature achievement if both pulls that
off I think that will be greater for his
legacy then what Phelps might be able to
do here in Rio which is add to his
already record haul of twenty two gold
medals but I don't think that would be
as distinctive to him as what both is
trying to do his films recognizes the
greatest olympian you know there's so
many ways you can come at that if you're
just going by pure metals one yes but of
course there are certain sports like
gymnastics and swimming where there are
more medals available are you can make
an argument that in terms of impact
Jesse Owens in 1936 had a greater
lasting impact and then he was the pride
of a chance to come back in nineteen
forty and 44 because of World War two
there were no Olympic Games and until
recent generations many athletes only
competed in one or two Olympics because
they had to be pure amateurs and they
had to go and make a living so Eric
Hyden went to a winter olympics 15 gold
medals in five attempts and then off to
become a doctor do you make an argument
for Carl Lewis because he like Jesse
Owens not only one sprint events but he
won the long jump there's so many
different ways to come at it but the
numerical argument for Phelps is hard to
refute he's Roberto Custis who joins us
live from real damn pass by the way let
me correct myself 22 total medals for
Phelps 18 of them gold American breakout
star do you have a name it could be some
on vials the gymnast under tensioning
because Aly Raisman and gabby douglas
are back from
fierce five that did so well in London
and and captured I think especially
Gabby just such a winning personality
captured everybody's affections but
Simone biles who's 19 years old has won
the last three World Championships so
she could be a breakout star from an
American perspective uh the Zika virus
uh pollution in some of the water
competitions as we found out once we got
to Sochi you know what was reported was
different than what we saw at sochi what
is the case with the with Rio well the
Olympic organizers and I've had
conversations with them believe that
they will have it under control will it
be no problem at all even they won't say
that but they believe they'll have it
under control the first thing they'd
cite is that August is actually winter
in Brazil now you near the equator so
it's not like people are going to be
bundled up it's still going to be warm
but it's not as hot not as humid the
mosquito population is much diminished
and so they believe that the Zika virus
would actually be a greater concern in
other parts of the world are by August
and it will be here in Brazil which
doesn't mean it's no concern at all I
spoke with the US ambassador and she
said that American tourists and they
expect more than a hundred thousand of
them to come for the Olympics maybe
close to 200,000 Americans to be there
go to travel.state.gov to arm educate
themselves about common sense steps they
should take if they're concerned about
the Zika virus if a concern about water
quality how many more Olympics you're
gonna host I'm on a case by case basis
my boy really yeah well I bye but I've
said that for a long time but what's it
hinge on that that like what would make
you not want to do it after Rio and what
would make you want to do it after real
you know I'd what would make me want to
continue to do it along with other
things that I do is how much I enjoy my
colleagues how much I respect what they
do arm the good feeling you get from
carrying the ball for them when you're
the host in prime time on the other hand
what would make me not want to do it is
that this will be my 11th time as the
prime time host and my twelfth Olympics
overall if you count late night in Seoul
in 1988 and you know you don't want to
overstay your welcome maybe to some
people I already have but I'd like to
I'd like to leave when it's my decision
rather than have someone wrapped their
arm around my shoulder and say hey you
know Bob here's a suggestion Oh a little
a little villa somewhere in Bermuda
wouldn't that be nice well they just
brought in Mike Tirico so who knows Bob
we're all in trouble you know at least
at least he's one of my surgeries guys
yeah and Sean McDonough will take over
Monday Night Football it's a whole
circus cabal nice hey great to hear from
you safe travels as always and I'll see
you in a in a few months all right then
take care that's a bob costas joining us
from copacabana beach the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience